[Music]
northwest gives her first tell-all
interview
and it's pretty much the cutest thing
ever
i want you to stay little forever okay
much to mama kim kardashian's dismay
four-year-old northey seems to be
growing up before our very
eyes such a trip check out these photos
of a very regal north posing alongside
kim as jackie o
for interview magazine why don't you
work what no what
no pictures but it's north's interview
with the mag that's really giving us
all the feels the best part other stars
kids are the ones asking all the
hard-hitting questions
cindy crawford's model daughter kaia
gerber asked about her family nickname
to which north replied bubs
she told britney spears's sons shawn and
jaden federline about her favorite song
it's amazing so amazing
so amazing
quote my daddy's song amazing so amazing
cool as for how north would like to
celebrate her next birthday
she revealed to stranger things star
millie bobby brown quote
i want all the princesses to come over
and the next time north and cousin
penelope disick have a baking party
it seems they'll be making rainbow
princess cake
it doesn't get much more adorbs than
this
[Music]